[Music]
since 2015
[Applause]
[Music]
could be worse she could have been at
Baylor that's Ashley and if we go to the
replay we will see that she did not have
it this is what happens when you're on
the sidelines at the Auburn LSU game and
you think you can shag kickoffs from a
Lou Groza Award finalist college
football gives people who couldn't get
into a decent school something to be
proud of game days are a rich tradition
of tailgating with other alcoholics and
screaming obscenities at 19 year olds
the coaches make millions of schools
make billions and the players are in
meaningless communications degrees some
equated to slavery which explains why
the south loves it so much in those
parts the only thing a father and son
enjoys throwing around more than a
football is the n-word 99% of all
college players won't make it to the NFL
which means there's a medical reason why
all the employees at a certain rental
car chain are suicidal but there's no -
9 - Lee's a gal who can take a hit to
the face so you know the NFL came
a-callin that's why I put her on the
first turnip truck out of Auburn
accompanied her to the draft and happily
took my 60% Commission for this week's
web Redemption
[Applause]
the 2017 NFL Draft
brought to you by concussion concussions
you're probably fine you should be so
proud your son slow super-agent in a
Rosenhaus how are you
nice suit Ellen oh you bought it
everybody at the draft wears this
[Applause]
[Music]
how are you you look great thank you
did you bust open your nose I did not
know injuries did he bleed no you can
take a hit all right where you from I'm
from Chicago originally right outside of
Chicago
what would possess the girl from Chicago
to go to school in Alabama it's a family
school so it goes way back on my mom's
side of the family what do you do in
Auburn go mudding you go money put in
pool wheel drive and just go through the
mud
yeah it can't be tell me about what
happened that day well I made a bet with
the managers on the football team that
I'd be able to catch the ball oh this
wasn't just like a random the kicker for
Auburn takes it to the same spot every
single time gotcha i sat there I'm gonna
get your face what did you what did you
feel nothing
it was a blur I fell back and I was like
oh I mean do you hate the fact that if
you google girls balls to face that
you're one of the first results
absolutely not my clients not going to a
team the draft of Mark Sanchez fifth
overall I don't think going to burn what
are their bad decisions have you made
coming on this show are you a proud of
the fact that you were the only
highlight from Auburn football in 2016
you ever dated a football player I
actually am dating a football player you
played at Auburn
what about there what about the
concussions you worry about that at all
I thought about it but footballs a hard
sport I mean I enjoy watching so much
never had a desire to play a single down
probably for the best right I'm pretty
frail
agile you're my mom to this day I don't
know how old she is god she's old but
she still thinks she could be a running
back in the NFL she's like oh no I just
have an ability to to Juke and get out
of the way I don't think people could
catch me and I always find it
fascinating that this old woman still
think she could be in the NFL Rex Ryan
football anymore
enjoy trying to sell your townhouse in
Buffalo do you think it would be a
female in the NFL with the way that
we're going into signing probably oh you
think it's society that's keeping women
out of football you don't think it's
their skillset okay I feel like they
need a kicker
I mean they've tried and they always
Chuck that girl up in Detroit Oh finally
they got her to the audition
she couldn't pick him 30 yeah
embarrassing you Belichick Trump did
they do standard concussion protocol on
you
yeah they had one of the team's doctors
come over and check me out of Auburn
okay so did they either rub tobacco on
you or just pray over you I say but I
just assumed that's what's going on down
in Alabama is prayer mandatory in your
school it is not but I would say 95% of
people probably do uh-huh that's nothing
wrong with praying I mean it doesn't
work but man nothing like making sure
your food gets a little colder the
families that do the hand-holding prayer
my family does hand-holding it's
uncomfortable brings you closer though I
hear you but then I have to talk about
how soft my hands are yes you guys get
sweaty
you got the sweaty palms in college
sweaty palms
yeah it's embarrassing really you can
take medication for it I've done
everything I did electroshock water do
guys comment when they hold your hands
for the first time know when I'm I mean
who would say something to you I would
because it'd be a deal breaker if we
didn't discuss it
it's great no people can't help a lot of
things that you're not attracted to we'd
have to talk about it because they can't
feel your hand oh yeah you look Nick
Saban now as an Auburn alum do you have
a message for him where you'll War Eagle
is that fun to yell it is
were you at Auburn when those inbred
folks over at Alabama poisoned your tree
I was how did that make you feel
I mean Bama sucks memories are Bama it
was that worse than a school shooting do
you think the treatment no I think you
answered it stop calling me Rams nobody
wants to play for your team let alone go
to your games that goes double for that
JV Chargers team NFL draft insider Mel
Kiper jr. jr. joining us this morning
Ashley's got a highly resilient face
she's definitely got what it takes to be
very popular in the locker rooms
she just set a record for the
most-watched slow-motion 40-yard dash
ever she's also the first athlete to
ever ace the Wonderlic drop passes never
stopped hitting junior from getting paid
that's the worst upper-body strength
since Chad Pennington yes there is a
video of her getting into a fight with a
female reporter that shouldn't affect
her draft stock the NFL has a history of
looking the other way and she is a girl
too I'll be honest with you she's never
made it to my little big board I find
her own draftable but bangable my
apologies
I've been up for four straight days my
wife left me and I'm not in a good place
you lack all the intangibles and
tangibles but lucky for you the draft
loves a viral sensation just look at
Michael Sam with the last pick of the
2017 NFL Draft Miami Dolphins select
modern University
[Music]
good news dolphin fans the Browns trade
their next four first-round picks for
[Music]
[Applause]